bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
françois hollande déclare dans
challenges il n'y aura pas de changement
de politique ni de ligne ni de premier
ministre un françois hollande droit dans
ses bottes c'est aussi ce qu'on attend
d'un président aux fonds non oui mais
s'il y avait une ligne ferme et si cette
ligne ferme et est en cohérence avec ce
qui a été promis aux français pendant la
campagne électorale et avec au fond le
socle d'une majorité qui le
soutiendraient ce serait exactement ce
qu'on attendrait alors vous voyez les
critiques que cela suppose de ma part
d'un côté je trouve que la ligne et peut
affirmer peu ferme
deuxièmement que ce n'est pas en
cohérence avec ce qui a été dit ou en
tout cas laissé entendre aux français et
ensuite c'est pas en cohérence avec la
majorité ce sont les trois faiblesses
vous voyez bien la gauche française
elle est aujourd'hui dans un dans un
mécanisme d'explosions dans un processus
d'explosion de séparation entre deux
lignes politiques qui sont radicalement
incompatibles et cette incompatibilité
là ça nous conduit à la situation
d'aujourd'hui
donc il faudra un changement de
politique je dis pas ça il faudrait une
politique c'est plus il faudrait une
politique plus affirmée ou clairement
affirmée ce qu'elle n'est pas
aujourd'hui est une politique qui
s'attaque aux problèmes principaux qui
explique la situation de la france alors
on peut les lister ces problèmes
principaux on a un problème très
important d'éducation nationale à
laquelle on va parler du collège
l'instant les réformettes ne peuvent pas
répondre
on a un problème de forme et aux
professionnels on a un problème de
lisibilité ou de complexité du droit du
travail
2 on a un problème d'instabilité
juridique et d'instabilité fiscales tout
ça ça fait beaucoup de problèmes pour la
cia de jean marais de réponse notamment
oui en tout cas ça explique le retard de
la france
alors les départementales c'est dans une
dizaine de une dizaine de jours on nous
promet un raz-de-marée front national
c'est inévitable d'ailleurs selon vous
je ne dis pas que ce soit inévitable où
ça n'aurait pas hésité inévitable mais
la situation fait que le front national
est le sujet unique de toutes les
conversations que les responsables
politiques y compris était le plus grave
les responsables politiques
gouvernementaux exprime à l'égard du
pays
il n'y a pas d'émission il n'y a pas de
bulletins de 2 journal d'information
dans lequel le front national ne soit
pas le sujet central
évidemment ça fait mécaniquement monter
l'opposant universel c'est le sujet
central parce que c'est devenu le
premier parti de france comme le
revendique marine le pen bien ce
qu'indiquent les intentions de vote
je ne dis pas le contraire et on a au
bout du compte la conséquence directe
des incapacités ou d impuissance dans
laquelle la vie politique en 16
s'enferme depuis des années est ce que
c'est une solution pour le pays
évidemment à mes yeux non le aucune des
solutions proposées que ce soit des
idées ou des obsessions par le front
national ne peut permettre de résoudre
les problèmes du pays
voilà c'est un besoin pour moi le
constat brutal dans le keirin à chaque
personnalité politique qui vient dans
cette émission le matin avant vous ces
derniers jours me dis dis à tous ceux
qui nous regardent ce n'est pas la bonne
méthode pour lutter contre le front
national il faut pas stigmatiser il faut
pas faire ceci ou au fond est ce qu'il
ya vraiment une solution aux soirées
n'ont peut-être 1
il y à une solution qui est de rendre
l'action politique estimable et efficace
ça c'est la solution elle ne peut pas
être estimable elle ne peut pas être
efficace parce qu'on continue à vouloir
les mêmes causes qui produiront les
mêmes effets ce alors les mêmes causes
une pseudo coupure de la france en deux
camps qui n'existe plus la gauche soit
disant contre la droite prétendu
deuxièmement on a une manière de
gouverner une gouvernance du pays qui
est à mon sens fait de communication et
pas de réalité est alors tant qu'on aura
les causes on aura les conséquences sur
sur cette lutte contre le front national
est ce que vous allez dire nous en
incluant les médias n'avons pas tous
tort ya un nouvel élément ce matin c'est
un sondage ifop fiducial paris-match sud
radio et i télé nous vous le révélions
ce matin c'est un sondage sur le regard
des habitants des communes front
national on savait tout juste un an qui
est des communes front national
maintenant donc que disent ses habitants
ils disent à 74% selon l'ifop qui sont
contents est-ce que ça ébranle pas un
peu vos convictions pourquoi vous vous
confondez beaucoup de plans premièrement
d'abord je sais pas comment le sondage
effet parce que sont sérieusement un
sondage sur laquelle qu on a combien de
fois dans quelques communes
mais admettons que le sondage soit le
reflet de la réalité pourquoi voulez
vous que les gens se déjuge au bout de
onze mois 74% en brossant voyons aucun
n'a été élu avec 3 à 3 bruce tout ça si
vous voulez faire là que nous fassions
la publicité ensemble de ceux de cette
proposition politique moi ne le ferai
pas il est normal que sur l'action
locale
les gens ne se déjuge pas au bout de
onze mois
c'est normal c'est parce que aussi clair
que je vous pose cette question c'est
bien de gimel je suis mère et je pense
en effet que le
les choix que prononce des citoyens une
communauté de citoyens il les juge pas
au bout de onze mois
mais ce que nous mettons en cause c'est
pas l'action locale du front national ce
dont je parle avec vous ça n'a rien à
voir avec le fait que la police
municipale ici ou à la une c'est quoi
les subventions aux associations
ailleurs soit touché ça n'a rien à voir
lille distinction selon vous entre la
politique locale menée par le front
national et la politique nationale
heureux mais faisons là n'essayons pas
d'amalgamé tout parce que là
l'inquiétude que le front national
suscitent chez au fond les plus
objectifs enfin cette inquiétude
elles portent uniquement sur le fait que
les solutions que le front national
propose sont des solutions qui si elle
était appliquée serait mortel pour le
pays
ça n'a rien à voir avec l commune avec
hénin beaumont gains béziers sanaryens
l'arbre au niveau national christiane
taubira par exemple n'est pas la seule
ce que ce n'est ni un parti républicain
ni démocratique c'est pas rien comme
déclaré
est ce que vous êtes sur cette même
ligne non non je ne pense quelle partie
je ne je ne pense pas que ce que manuel
valls a appelé à mon avis maladroitement
la stigmatisation ne pense pas que ce
soit un bon moyen de convaincre les
électeurs
je ne je ne crois pas et même plus vous
charger la barque du point de vue des
accusations plus évidemment les
électeurs se retourne alors que ça veut
dire
c'est un parti qui est dans le champ
légal
mais ces valeurs ne ressemble pas aux
valeurs de l'éducation civique on va
dire les choses comme ça et vous voyez
que c'est une distinction qui est très
importante et je n'ai employés ni le mot
républicain ni le mode démocratique
parce que c'est trop facile à renverser
et donc le
il me semble que les critiques apportées
apporte plus souvent de l'eau au moulin
de ceux qu'on veut cibler que le
contraire et je trouve donc il ya une
maladresse peut-être dû au hasard ou
manque de sensibilité mais peut-être
voulu aussi parce que il ya peut-être
aussi de ici ou là des arrière pensées
qui viserait à trouver en faisant monter
le front national a trouvé des
situations qu'on n'a pas jusqu'à
maintenant
françois bayrou on peut rappeler vous
avez été ministre de l'éducation
nationale ces sujets d'éducation vous
intéresse au premier plan vous les avez
la cité en premier tout à l'heure et
vous avez aussi dit réforme est là vous
pensiez à ce qu'annonce ayez à najat
vallaud belkacem sur le collège
oui ou même on est on est très loin de
ce que à devrait imposer la situation de
l'éducation nationale alors réforme du
collège ça fait partie des figures
imposées vous savez en patinage
il ya les figures libres et à les
figures imposées les exercices qu'il
faut faire et franchement des dents des
figures imposées
est-ce que ça l'a7 entre guillemets
réforme ou sept
ces changements à la marge annoncée dans
l'organisation du collège
est-ce que ça a la moindre chance de
résoudre les problèmes de l'éducation
nationale en france pour moi la réponse
est évidemment non c'est une réponse
aveuglante
alors on peut dire très rapidement les
choses il faudrait revenir sur l'idée du
collège unique selon vous pour ces cinq
fonds suggère le le sujet principal
c'est l'école primaire d'accord si vous
allez au collège avec des élèves qui ont
10 ans 11 ans 12 ans quelquefois pas à
l'entrée en sixième et qui n'ont aucun
moyen de comprendre ce qu'on leur dit ou
d'exprimer ce qu'ils ont à l'intérieur
d'eux ou de découvrir par le texte par
la lecture que vous avez sous les yeux
de découvrir les idées les faits les
réalités de ce qui est très importante
dans les échanges entre les êtres
humains vous aurez beau changer les
horaires à la marge
vous aurez beau dire on va apprendre la
deuxième langue à partir de la 5ème vous
croyez que dell ajoutent ils
et rien de tout ça gagnera a commencé la
deuxième langue en 5e de manière
obligatoire si j'ai bien compris et en
monopolisant tous les moyens disponibles
et supplémentaires tout ça me paraît
très très très très loin de la réalité
je vais vous dire hier madame
vallaud belkacem a cité deux exemples de
révolution on va faire un dossier sur la
machine à vapeur dit elle et d'un autre
côté on va faire calculer aux élèves
combien de temps on gagne en allant par
le train dans une ville éloignée plutôt
qu'aller à cheval alors là ça ressemble
au problème du cours élémentaire
autrefois à l'école primaire et l'autre
si vous croyez que le dossier sur la
machine à vapeur va permettre à l'enfant
de deux hauts-fourneaux de 2,2 de se
donner les moyens de la compréhension et
de l'expression je crois moi que c'est
très très loin de la réalité
françois bayrou j'aimerais pour terminer
vous interroger sur cette loi sur la fin
de vie qui étaient débattus et adoptés à
l'assemblée
cette nuit est ce que cette nouvelle
version vous va sa chance est un sujet
extrêmement sensible
est-ce que ce que propose désormais les
députés le gouvernement va dans le bon
sens c'est un sujet extrêmement sensible
et intime
alors je veux dire ce que je crois pour
moi imaginez qu'on doit faire une loi
générale pour traiter de la multiplicité
des problèmes et des drames et des
angoisses que suscite la fin de vie
à mon sens c'est l'enkr pas adapté donc
avant même de capter de ce qu'il ya dans
la loi vous considérez qu'il chez bud et
député à l'époque la loi léonetti qui
était la première loi sur la fin de vie
que je trouvais bien inspiré après il ya
des situations et elle a été votée je
vous rappelle à l'unanimité et pour
faire voter à quelqu'un comme moi une
loi sur la fin de vie
faux voilà faut avoir fait un travail
qui est un travail sérieux c'est le le
le on est dans une situation où on a une
multitude de cas différents de
souffrance différentes et moi je trouve
que les médecins
avec leur conscience et le le débat
entre eux et la concertation entre eux
la conscience médicale et la conscience
de personnes humaines à personne humaine
c'est la réponse la plus adaptée qu'on
puisse trouver alors qu'on qui est des
marges de réponse mais qu'on veuille
traiter d'une loi générale au fond un
grand nombre de ceux qui défendent cette
loi veulent aller sur une tan asie ce
test à dire le le fait de donner la mort
et notre civilisation
elle est fondée sur le respect de la vie
et donc il ya là un conflit
philosophique que je dirais intime
profond que pour moi je me sous-estimer
pas merci françois bayrou
bonne journée à vous dans un instant
demain de 8h30 sur i télé